كانت أصغر امرأة منتخبة على الإطلاق
كرئيسة للحكومة ، والثانية
التي تلد من منصب ،
وقد واجهت في السنوات الخمس الماضية سلسلة من
التحديات غير المسبوقة قبل وقت قصير
أعلنت جاسيندا أرديرن أنها
ستتنحى عن منصب رئيس الوزراء النيوزيلندي.
وزيرة في غضون ثلاثة أسابيع عندما تحدثت في
معتكف لحزب العمال في نابير في
الجزيرة الشمالية ، لم أختنق لأنها
وصفت كيف تسبب وقتها في المنصب
في إلحاق الضرر بها وتركها مرهقة ،
كما أعلنت عن إجراء انتخابات عامة في
أكتوبر
هذا الصيف.  كنت تأمل في إيجاد طريقة
للتحضير ليس فقط لسنة
أخرى ولكن لفترة أخرى لأن هذا ما
يتطلبه هذا العام
لم أتمكن من القيام
بذلك ولذا أعلن اليوم أنني
لن أسعى لإعادة انتخابي
ومن ثم فترة ولايتي  كرئيسة للوزراء
ستختتم في موعد أقصاه السابع من
فبراير
، لا أريد الثناء في جميع أنحاء العالم على
تعاملها مع الوباء الخفي
لأسلوب شخصي في التحدث من
القلب خاصة أثناء الأم.
أزمة مثل إطلاق النار الجماعي على
مسجدين في كرايستشيرش في عام 2019 في غضون
أسابيع ، أقرت أرديرن وحكومتها العمالية
قوانين الأسلحة التي تحظر
الأسلحة شبه الآلية جيدًا ،
نمت الشعبية في جميع أنحاء العالم في
الأشهر الأخيرة ، وتباطؤ الاقتصاد ،
وأزمة الإسكان والتضخم الذي شهده
تنخفض تقييمات موافقتها في المنزل